speaking of which up so lately I've been
doing these longer YouTube live streams
I had an hour or 75 minute sort of
debate conversation with Stephen Bernal
who's a streamer known as destiny we
talked about ad boycotts as a strategy
in politics last week I did a 75 minute
conversation with Tim Poole an
independent journalist about free speech
and platforming and Twitter there were
some disagreements there were some
agreements but in both cases we took
about 60 or 75 minutes to figure out in
more depth what do we agree about what
do we disagree about and people seem to
be really liking the format if not
always the specific people that I'm
interviewing so my question to you is
who else do you want me to quote debate
or have a conversation with in which we
explore disagreements I know a lot of
people often say debate Ben Shapiro I
think that he's probably too big for the
show at this point rightly or wrongly I
think that that's the perception at this
point in time so I don't know that he
would do it but if he did what would the
topic be I'm open to ideas some of the
folks you suggest maybe we've already
reached out to others not but let me
know who you would like to see in a
long-form conversation with me and we'll
try to make it happen I will also have
some in-person stuff to announce soon as
well these aren't a hundred percent
finalized so I won't give all the
details yet but in the next six to eight
months I will probably be doing an
in-person event in Rochester New York
which will be open to the public for a
small fee it'll be part of a broader
conference and I'm insisting that they
make just that event just my talk open
to the public
for a small fee without having to sign
up for the entire conference I've got
something coming up in Texas I'm not
even gonna say we're in Texas yet but I
will have more details about that LA is
looking more and more likely although I
don't know if that will be public
appearances or just a few interviews
which I might be doing but in any case
everything I do for an organization or a
conference I always insist let's make it
open to the public at least with a
ticket not just conference participants
or members of your organization and
usually most people are
to that speaking invitations get in
touch using the contact form on the
website 20:19 is filling up and I'm
actually already looking at some
twenty20 events so get in touch and I'll
just say ahead of time because people
later get mad there does have to be a
budget you know at this point I'm I'm
lucky enough to get enough requests
where I don't have to travel on my own
time across the country and pay my own
way there for unpaid events but I do
work with organizations that have a
variety of budgets so it's always worth
getting in touch and at at least three
very exciting things to announce in the
very very near future